it's stressful for them
oh my God if I would show my booty I
would be like
[Music]
twitch used to be about this now it's
about this female Gamers and sports bras
asmr's dreams that are actually about
the visuals and who could forget the
infamous hot tub streamers at one point
in time twitch was fighting back on this
type of content pretty hard they would
permaband streamers for the slightest of
offenses Shadow banned their content and
or disable advertising for such channels
but over the years it just become more
and more liberal in fact they've
actually turned to embracing more mature
content for example two years ago they
added the hot tub category into twitch
and more recently they have even gone as
far as unbanning streamers who are known
for pushing their boundaries like Indie
Fox I mean her channel name itself has
two x's in it surely that's just a
coincidence it's not really surprising
why so many streamers have turned to
this content the bottom line is that
it's simply extraordinarily lucrative
take streamer Karina up for example she
is one of the biggest names when it
comes to streamers with an of and when
she switched to oraph she made a 4
million in the first month and a million
at the next month according to another
streamer named elidity when she
transitioned to oaf she made more in a
month than she would have made on Twitch
in 10 years and that's not to say that
they were making a small amount on
Twitch itself and given that twitch he
gets 50 of the revenue that streamers
pull in through the platform it's no
wonder why they've turned to promoting
this content but at what cost there's no
denying that mature content is very much
taboo even in Western societies and how
many parents would want their kids
watching content on a platform that
promotes this safe to say not that many
it's also likely that streamers will
have a lot more hesitancy when it comes
to using the platform if twitch becomes
known for its mature content then you
simply want to stream gaming content
it's more than likely that you choose to
stream on YouTube instead so it looks
like twitch may be digging their own
grave when it comes to the general
audience but how did things get so bad I
mean there's plenty of creators who do
the same thing on YouTube as well likely
the most notable example is Bel Delfina
but YouTube is by no means known for
this content so here's twitch's
Devolution from gaming and reaction
content to not save for work content
foreign
taking a look back the downfall of
twitch can actually be traced back to
their most recent search which was
actually three years ago at this point
right at the beginning of the pandemic
in April of 2020 which is streamers and
viewership basically doubled concurrent
streams went from just over 50 000 to a
hundred thousand and the concurrent
viewership went from 1.4 million to 2.4
million this momentum carried into early
2021 but by the summer twitch was
starting to show the first signs of
plateauing and now that we're two years
out this trend is even clearer from a
normal person perspective this is by no
means a problem twitch had simply
reached its Pinnacle and it was starting
to stabilize like any mature company but
from Amazon's perspective this was a
nightmare if you didn't know Amazon is
one of the most infamous growth
companies of all time in the past 13
years they haven't even had a single
quarter of a negative year-over-year
growth but to achieve this they've made
some pretty massive bets in fact they've
basically sacrificed all trace of
profitability they just reinvest
everything they make and if they still
have profit left over they'll just keep
prices the same until inflation catches
up this is because the company strongly
believes that your margin is their
opportunity So in theory if they have no
margin no one else will have any
opportunity and they have very much ran
twitch with this same mindset despite
being a ginormous platform it's not
clear if twitch is or ever was
profitable after all it's not cheap to
stream and store hundreds of millions of
hours worth of content this is the main
reason that twitch doesn't really
support 4K streaming it's estimated that
in 2019 it cost Amazon 1.8 billion
dollars to run twitch but they only
pulled in 1.54 billion worth of Revenue
the pandemic boom may have pushed twitch
into profitability but only slightly if
at all and the problem is that these
wonky economics only work if the company
is constantly growing at 20 30 40 per
year stagnation is seen as a catastrophe
and twitch hasn't just been stagnating
they've actually been declining in fact
in November of 2022 twitch had its
largest viewership drop in years of 10
again this isn't to say that twitch is
dying it was just cooling off from the
pandemic boom as people started doing
other stuff again but I think you can
imagine the discounted faces of Amazon
Executives after seeing this performance
why wasn't twitch growing Tick Tock was
growing Instagram was growing and even
YouTube which had been out for way
longer was still growing what was twit
doing wrong well the answer was that
they simply appealed to a much more
Niche demographic due to their business
model unlike most popular services today
twitch actually makes most of their
money from users directly paying
creators and there's very few niches in
which this strategy will work so by
Nature twitch was limited by how much
they could grow and they were left with
two options either they could focus on
promoting free content and appealing to
a broader audience or they could cut
costs let's just say twitch would
aggressively choose the latter
usually platforms like YouTube are quite
generous when it comes to revenue
sharing with creators and the reasoning
isn't rocket science the more that
creators make the more that these
platforms so it's in their best interest
to align incentives and lock-in creators
this is why YouTube has been handing out
exclusivity deals left and right and why
Spotify paid Joe Rogan 200 million
dollars to switch to Spotify but for a
few years now twitch has been doing the
exact opposite and the creators who gave
twitch the confidence to do this were
none other than ninja and a shroud two
of the platform's most popular streamers
you see it back in late 2019 Microsoft
paid these creators a stupid amount of
money to switch to their streaming
platform mixer they paid ninja 50
million and a shrouded 10 million at
first this was seen as a massive loss
for twitch Microsoft had literally
bought out two of their biggest creators
but to most people surprise it which is
viewership it didn't really go down
after these creators left and to make
things even better for twitch Microsoft
would actually shut down mixer in
mid-2020 and that both streamers would
return to Twitch for free this was
twitch's light bulb moment the bottom
line was that these creators had nowhere
else to go sure there are some
exceptions like Ludwig who have been
able to successfully transition to
YouTube but for the most part streamers
only have one option twitch and
according to former twitch employees the
company would leverage this as much as
possible they would start renewing
contracts with the top streamers with
less favorable conditions and they were
even rooting for top streamers to leave
as it gave up and coming streamers more
room to grow apparently ninja leaving
gave room for five to six new streamers
to take his place this wasn't no doubt a
new strategy for streaming platforms but
it was by no means a new strategy for
Amazon I'm sure you're all familiar with
the terrible working conditions of
Amazon workers you've probably wondered
why Amazon doesn't just fix these issues
to improve employee satisfaction and
retention well the answer is that they
literally want employees to leave
whenever you get a new job you'll
probably work your ass off to build up a
good reputation but as you become more
tenured you'll likely become more
comfortable and settle into a more
normal working schedule Jeff Bezos sees
this Evolution as a march to mediocrity
so Amazon tries to avoid this at all
costs instead they want people to join
Amazon work a crap ton see that no one
recognizes their efforts and then leave
this way they can repeat this same
process with the next soccer in line
there is no doubt that this is a toxic
strategy but it's worked for them quite
well over the past two decades and now
they're applying the same strategy to
Twitch hungry creators jump onto the
platform and grind away on content
hoping that just maybe they can make it
once they make it though they realize
that twitch isn't actually all that
friendly and they either get burnt out
or switched to YouTube this doesn't
really matter for twitch though as
there's hundreds of thousands of
creators who would be happy to take
their place while effective it this has
made twitch into the same meat grinder
as Amazon
all of these cuts on the Creator side
worked out quite well for twitch
financially in fact twitch just stole
actively cutting perks for creators in
late 2022 for example twitch nerfed
craters with a 70 30 Revenue split down
to 50 50 after the first 100 000. this
was an especially Savage move because
streamers were actually asking for all
creators to be boosted to a 70 30 model
but twitch went ahead and it did the
exact opposite but while all these moves
made twitch less of a money pit it
didn't solve twitch's original problem
which was stagnating growth what they
needed it was a new Creator generated
content that appealed to a larger
demographic that people were willing to
pay for directly there was really only
one genre that accomplished this and
that's of course simp content to be
honest it's not surprising why this
content would perform so well on Twitch
the platform is literally filled with
decently well-off anti-social Gamers so
it's no wonder why these people ate up
thirst traps and E thoughts its life
that they didn't want to associate with
this content or have it tarnished a
brand of twitch or Amazon but it seems
like all of their worries flurried away
when they saw other platforms were doing
the same thing particularly Instagram
and Tick Tock I mean half the content on
Tick Tock is crap like this and as for
Instagram let's be honest ain't no one
following fitness models because they
inspired them to work out or something
even YouTube has turned to this type of
content when it comes to shorts so
somewhere along the line it which
figured if everyone else is doing it why
shouldn't we we should also mention that
another risque website has blown up over
the past couple of years the success of
this platform likely just motivated
twitch even more to make the switch and
it doesn't buy the content on Twitch
today it looks like they've definitely
made the switch
foreign
looking forward it doesn't seem like
things will get any better just one
month ago twitch's co-founder and mature
stepped down as CEO so now it's truly
just a bunch of amazonians who are
looking for maximum growth and don't
really care about the soul of the
platform so you can bet that twitch's
Creator policies will just get even less
friendly they'll become even more of a
meat grinder and they're gonna Embrace
any Avenue that allows them to continue
growing now of course I don't think
they'll turn to full-on adult content
but with that being said I do believe
that they'll continue to push the
boundaries in terms of what's acceptable
for a mainstream platform and a given
that Instagram and Tick Tock are very
much willing to do the same thing which
is days as the gaming platform may very
well be coming to an end and that's the
sad state of twitch do you approve of
the new direction of twitch comment that
down below also drop a like if you
missed the old twitch and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community to adjust with your video
ideas and to consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]